expecto patronum
we love everything about the Harry
Potter franchise it made us believe in
magic and that's all thanks to you JK
Rowling you truly created one of the
most amazing universes of all time we
loved everything from the books to the
movies to the actors who portrayed the
golden trio we're so happy that most of
them respected the many rules set out
for them because we can't imagine what
would have happened if one of them got
the boot but we have to admit we were
more than a little disappointed when we
didn't receive our Hogwarts invitation
on our 11th birthday but whatever we're
over it just sort of landing a recurring
role on a huge franchise like Harry
Potter is no small feat actors have a
set of rules that they're expected to
follow and it doesn't matter how old or
young these actors are everyone is
expected to respect their contracts keep
watching to find out which actor made a
mess of things and lived to regret it
franchise bound in the past actors have
been sued for quitting movies I needed
all the support I could have so to
become part of the Harry Potter guild
actors had to sign contracts designed to
stop them from leaving the cast
recasting a big-time role midway through
a franchise is a total nightmare you
know that transition the breaking of
innocence so more often than not only an
actor's passing can excuse them from the
contract unfortunately Richard Harris
who played Albus Dumbledore in the first
two movies passed away and had to be
recast don't date your co-stars it's
totally normal for actors to fall in
love on set especially when they're
acting out romantic scenes problem is if
they date and break up while the
franchise is still going strong things
can get a little messy so it's no
surprise that the cast of Harry Potter
was heavily encouraged to keep their
feelings to themselves suddenly we
understand why Emma Watson never came
clean about her feelings for tom Felton
no fighting on set filming schedules are
crazy enough as it is and the last thing
directors want is to have to babysit two
actors who constantly keep bickering
this was a concern when casting Helena
bonham-carter and Emma Thompson who
played Bellatrix Lestrange and Sybill
Trelawney respectively as it turns out
these ladies
had a troubling history that would have
put them at odds if they hadn't let
bygones be bygones so what happened
between them well in 1994 Emma's husband
was secretly dating Helena while
shooting a movie with her which resulted
in Emma getting a divorce
yikes and I would I could find in my
heart that I had learned to keep a
secret in 2007 JK Rowling finished
writing Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows which would serve as the last
book of the series that same year the
fifth Harry Potter movie had just hit
the big screen and while the world still
didn't know how the series would end
many of the actors did JK Rowling had
filled them in on her plans to help them
get into character my worst fear my
personal worst fear so one of the most
important rules was to keep these
spoilers to themselves be on your best
behavior millions of adults may have
watched the Harry Potter movies but most
of its fan base consisted of kids and
teenagers so it was of dire importance
for the cast to be on their best
behavior scandals were simply not
permitted in anyone who made headlines
for the wrong reasons risked being
kicked out of the cast keep watching to
find out which character had to be
replaced when his actor got arrested in
real life don't steal the props it takes
a lot of time and effort to create movie
props especially when dealing with
magical productions like Harry Potter
still now and then actors get caught
with sticky fingers and props in their
pockets these props can be sold for a
lot of money on eBay but the price of
getting caught can be even more
expensive don't steal the props isn't a
recommendation it's a rule that if
broken can ruin an actor's career no
substance abuse Harry Potter fans were
stunned when blaze the beanie replaced
Vincent Krabs character in the final
installment but as it turns out Jamie
Whalen who portrayed Crabbe had gotten
himself into some legal trouble after
partaking in substance abuse violent
disorder and theft
it was strictly forbidden for Harry
Potter actors to use illegal substances
but unfortunately Jamie didn't take this
rule seriously and paid the ultimate
price here at the things we post daily
videos about all your favorite movies TV
shows and actors if you like staying up
to date with the
latest news hit that subscribe button
and click the bell to be notified
whenever we post a new video if you're
watching on your mobile go on your
YouTube settings and turn on
notifications this way you can be the
first to comment on our newest videos
and that's a wrap on the seven rules the
cast of Harry Potter had to follow
before you go tell us which animal your
Patronus would take shape of in the
comments below and that's a wrap
subscribe to the things and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll catch you
later